[Music]  hi I'm Danny ran in a way a long time  let's go you know here I'm Danny Rand  welcome I left here ten years old and a  jet my parents I became the lone  survivor Danny ran back from the dead  why didn't waited this long to show up  how the hell did he learn martial arts  ready drain come on  my father instilled in me a love and  respect for this company that has never  faded this is my home brand is my  company  this city is no place for daddy  we will give it up no to Rivet were many  what happened to you why are you really  back here some bad people gun on the  inside  criminals I know what they are but they  can do despise them we need someone with  special skills I've been training my  whole life  [Music]  I'm  I'm going with you so you're not  you need the change is coming down  [Music]  become would-be were meant to be  I am the iron fence  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]